Ooo, hello, lovely viewer of
the Slow Mo Guys, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
See usually I don't say
that first bit, and then
Put me off
I have to say it was confusing wasn't it.
Yeah
This is a lovely short little video.
I've got myself here a
percussive massage device.
Sort of like a meat
pulverizer of a massage.
Are you gonna give me a massage with that?
Well, sort of.
Sweet.
It looks like a power tool.
Sounds like a power tool.
Well that's kind of scary.
You're going to massage
my face with that, god.
Ah, ah.
We'll do some of that,
in slow mo, obviously.
All right, okay.
You ready?
What kind of expression
do you want me to go for?
Just keep your face jowly and lose.
You ready?
Yep, ah, ah!
Do you know what I think's
happened there, right.
Is, do you know the bottom of your eye?
You know, it's like your nose is there.
You can see your nose.
Yeah
My cheek was coming,
like, into my eye line.
I think it was shooting
my cheek up into my eye.
This is stupid.
Well, uh, yes Dan, yes it is.
Whoa.
Oh look at it ripple.
It's like it's splashing water.
It's like a stone dropping
in your face pond.
Because
Because I'm completely still,
relative to that, apart from when I blink,
it looks like I'm like a wax model
Yeah
For like a stunt thing on TV.
You're getting pummeled.
God, how many punches per second is it?
Let's have a look.
It's happening almost once a second
at 1,000 FPS so it's probably
close to 40 times a second.
Damn
All right so because
I was slightly worried
about hurting you I think
you should do it to yourself,
because you know the limits of it.
But also, do some extra face flapping.
Kind of like the flappy faces video
from like seven years ago.
I'll do some eyework
Eyework
Get in some lip movement.
Yeah maybe a bit of spit
if you can handle it.
Oh yeah yeah.
Stop, stop.
Because the screen is only
updating so many times
I'm just getting like
tons of freeze frames
of your face and all stupid.
You know when you like hold a plastic bag
out of the window of a car?
That's exactly what it looks like.
That's ridiculous.
Ah.
Love it.
Well, since I'm also
more jowelly than I was
since I first did that.
Okay so we've angled
slightly with the sun,
just to have less of
his face in the shade,
and there's a very zoomed
in lens on there now.
So it's gonna be like
this, this is the framing.
I'm not sure I've ever filmed you
this close up in 4K before.
Oh, you'll have to, like,
cut in and see my pores.
Yeah
Oh you really are close.
That is uh, slightly horrific isn't it?
Oh there's spit everywhere as well.
It's like going out of
sync with you mouth.
Oh it's like pushing my mouth sideways
from one side to the other.
You are your own Gary's mod.
All right any other
alternatives you wanna do?
Well we've just done, sort
of, soggy cheek at the minute.
Yeah
I wanna see if I can hit the bone here,
and if it like jiggles my
eye sockets all around.
It might be a bit painful so
it might be a bit shorter,
because I might be like, "Ow ow ow ow ow!"
It's like getting punched in the eye.
You might get a black eye.
Did it hurt?
It's not nice.
It's like, pulsating my other eyeball.
It's rattling your whole head.
It's like bashing your skull over.
Like the other eye gets moved.
You can see the eye fat,
like underneath my eyes, jiggling inside.
Look at it.
Oh it's moving your whole front.
It's going down to my
jowls and everything,
and my nose is being moved too.
Look at all the skin that's
just being compressed there.
It's like squishing
together, giving me wrinkles,
but what is that part of the nose called.
I mean is it the nostril area?
The frenulum.
The fenu
It's not called a frenulum.
That's not what that is?
We should do my your nose.
We should do your nose.
My nose.
I think that's better.
Ahhhh!
It makes me want to sneeze.
It's like a ripple that sends it
all around the other nostril.
All your nose skin up to the bridge
is like being shoved around by it.
Oh that's so much flap.
You can see exactly where my nose bone is.
That was so much beyond my bone.
It's literally doing this, like.
All right Dan what would you say
is the fleshiest part of you?
That we can show on YouTube
probably my peck or like maybe my gut.
Okay, whip off that kit.
Look at all the ripples going through.
It really travels.
It does it.
It looks like my arm is actually
connected to my peck completely.
It just looks like water.
It's just sticking to it slightly.
Yeah
It's like pulling it out, putting it in.
Oh that's gross.
This might be jowly.
Look, if you look at my back there,
I'm relaxed and the then tense and then
Oh yeah, let's try that.
Push against me, all right and yeah go.
Then it like shakes the
whole back, you see that?
It's so weird.
It goes from like water,
rippling along you,
to just jiggling the entire muscle.
Yeah the muscle locks up,
and then it becomes a
complete solid object
Yeah.
Just rattling your whole back.
It's almost like, yeah,
it's like the outside is rippling
and the middle part is a solid slab,
just getting shoved around.
Well Dan I think we've learned a lot
about you face, and head,
and body, and things.
Fully massaged now.
Nice and tender.
Yeah.
It was actually really cool
when you flexed the muscle,
because instead of just sending ripples
through like a puddle, it was like
your moving a whole state.
It was like your whole
back was getting pushed.
Like the skin locked up
Yeah
And it just moved the entire thing,
rather than like a ripple.
That and the skull I liked.
I almost want to use
this for another video.
Like maybe liquids or something.
Get sort of like a
Pummeling some stuff.
Paint on a speaker,
yeah, maybe some oobleck.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to subscribe
to the Slow Mo Guys,
follow us on social media, and stuff,
and we'll see you right
back here in the next video.
Gucci.